Ví giá nhá bên tên gần tầu dòng ông tổ hốc trái sử dồi,
hỏi đàn buổi cao vào sáng 14.
Hỏa hoạn thác ra từ cân nhà các vốn dộ khoảng 5.5,
để sau trộ bị chương, tưởng bị chương.
Lúc này, nhiều người xung quanh của gắng giúp lợi xong bất thành.
I Phu Sao, lợi bùng lên và lan sản hai cân khác.
Ví giá nhà này hầu hết là phải gỗ, máy tôn, năm vên cân.
Vúc đó, thì thì thấy nó cũng bừng bừng bừng lên,
mình cũng sản áo lên, lúc mà cái dữ lưa nữa.
Nó mấy cái nấu bừng lên mà mấy cái mình gái này vậy hông biết?
Như tụi thơ quyền trong nả lộ trợ, đã dây hả quán như hục dự rấy thương phẩm để chân trái lan.
Bây giờ trái cùng hơn 8.4 đến hiện trường giọc lưa.
Sau 8 mi khu quán lợi được không trái,
quyền nhân buổi trái đang được làm gió.